Super Mario maker has been out for a
month now and it turns out a bunch of
you are just pretty faces you're also
super talented level creators here some
of the coolest and craziest levels that
I've come across in Super Mario maker so
far now putting this one first because
while I know there are those of us who
get a good laugh out of a troll there
are others who would say that that kind
of trick has no place in a top levels
video I'm talking Rick rolls you can
find a couple of different levels that
are entitled all the costumes unlocked
or harvest level ever which sounds
pretty appealing but what you get if you
try them out is this yeah what these
levels do showcase though is the clever
things you can do with the games music
blocks to generate shoes so it's not
really a shitty troll okay well it is
but it's a clever shitty troll if you
came for the sweet tunes but not the
trolling you can check out a level
called rhythmic run which perfectly
matches the in-game sound effects to the
backing feel free to take this moment to
cringe at how long that must have taken
to get right I've tried to find a little
something for everybody in this list
video so if you want to be challenged do
I have the level for you it's pretty
widely believed that the pit of panga
pee break level by Pangaea panga is the
hardest level made to date in Super
Mario maker watching the game play right
now should give you a pretty good idea
of why perfect timing and executions are
required to get you to the end of this
excruciating experiment in human
patients but at least you'll snag those
sweet bragging rights if you can beat it
these next couple are favorites of mine
for subverting typical Mario tropes this
first one is called peaches escape
monorail and it depicts peach getting
her own damn self out of her kidnapping
pickle no Mario required you begin down
in a prison room of bowser's castle and
fight your way back out the way Mario
would usually head in running left in
the whole way it's pretty adorable
seeing teach in her floating parasol
dodging fireballs to ultimately find
yourself at the end of a traditional
Mario surface level where you even
arrive at the flag from the right hand
side after escaping Bowser's dungeon
you're probably already clued into the
fact that everybody's favorite plumber
is a big big fan of mushrooms that's
what makes winners don't do shrooms by
keiko be so great basically you'll want
to forget everything you know about
mushrooms in Mario to make it through
this one you'll need to avoid every
single mushroom of which there are an
obscene amount in order to make it
through as there are many areas that
only have space for regular mini Mario
to pass through luckily for you the
Creator has placed a couple of piranha
plants checkpoints so you can get small
again at certain points in the level
finally while gimmicky levels and
universe mashups are all the rage I
think the top slot has been well earned
by bunny as their Super Mario maker
world alright so I'm really violating my
top five levels proposal by including
this one but trust me it's worth it
funny super mario maker world is an
eight world 60 stage monster over
creation that you can play through in
its entirety if you're interested in
Super Mario maker stems from wanting to
play lengthy link stages with an
increasing difficulty curve and this is
for you the Creator is called the pack
of themed walls a full game super mario
world tribute and there's even a trailer
out for it so you can see just what
you're in for those are a few of my
favorites but be sure to let me know
which Super Mario maker levels have
caught your eye and which ones are your
favorites I'll catch you again next week